[Music]  maybe it's down  [Music]  [Applause]  please tell me  [Music]  [Applause]  Dick's love to change my new digs love  to try  you know man in the old days I always  knew like you were gonna do something  that you'd be alright it's the first  time I worried about you  [Music]  can I ask you a personal question  okay tell me something  do you write songs or anything I don't  sing my own songs why I just don't feel  comfortable why won't you feel  comfortable almost every single person  has told me they like the way I sounded  but that they didn't like the way I look  I think you're beautiful  hey what I just wanna take another look  at you you know  and I find myself  [Music]  Jane  come sing that song what I love no I  can't do that  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]